alleged victims of Jeffrey Epstein
planned to speak in court this morning
in what one attorney says will be an
historic hearing up to 30 women are
expected to accept in New York judge's
invitation to address the hearing before
he moves to dismiss the criminal sex
trafficking case against Epstein have
seen as you know took his own life
earlier this month molla Yankees at the
federal courthouse in Manhattan with
more on this story Moeller what do you
think we can expect today
well good morning Gail the defense
attorneys for Jeffrey Epstein as well as
some of the attorneys representing some
of these alleged victims are expected to
speak at today's hearing in addition to
some of the victims that you mentioned
the federal sex trafficking and
conspiracy to sex trafficking charges
against Epstein are expected to
ultimately be dismissed after it appears
he hanged himself in his jail cell
earlier this month the Federal Judge
Richard Berman could announce that
dismissal today but first Berman
scheduled this morning's hearing to
allow Epstein's alleged victims to speak
Epstein was accused as we know of
sexually abusing dozens of women
including underage girls CBS News has
obtained alleged victim statements that
are expected to be read in court today
one Jane Doe said I understand his case
may be dismissed or closed but this
makes me feel as though I and anyone
else who fell prey to his hands simply
do not matter I ask that you very
seriously consider the final decision
it's the same women but went on to say
in choosing death Epstein
denied everyone justice Gail yeah we
keep hearing those women have a lot to
say molla so what happens when the
criminal case is dismissed
well of course there are civil cases
that are being brought by Epstein's
accusers those will continue to move
forward those are very much alive and
investigators prosecutors say that they
will continue to pursue and investigate
any possible co-conspirators who may
have helped Epstein run his alleged sex
trafficking operation and of course
there are federal investigations that
are ongoing by the Department of Justice
as well as by Congress that are looking
into how Epstein was able to apparently
hang himself in that Federal
Correctional Facility while he was
awaiting trial and of course we'll be
following those molla thank you very
much